You’ve probably had a game like this—somebody
starts to do some nutty stuff surprisingly
early in the game, really going ham with their
pieces of cardboard, and by the time they’ve
achieved a decisive win a handful of turns
later, one or more other players are sitting
dejectedly and grumbling to themselves that
this matchup was unfair.
Power level differences within a table can
be a tricky thing to navigate, you know, it’s
not so fun if a game ends up being an absolute
blowout, with some players feeling like they
didn’t even get a chance, and I’d generally
encourage trying to coordinate power levels
to some degree.
But, do you wanna know a secret?
In most cases like this, the relative power
levels of the decks aren’t even the main
issue.
Decks with varied power levels can work fine
in the same pod, and games can avoid this
“blowout” issue, but this requires a couple
things to be true, and the first one of these
things is very simple: decks should run interaction.
I mentioned in my last video how a key table
dynamic that keeps powerful decks in check
in a multiplayer format is the ability for
multiple other players to trade cards one
for one with a player who is ahead.
And I don’t think I need to say much else
to make clear the problem with a lot of casual
EDH tables—they can’t do this because
they don’t run enough ways to trade cards
like.
A lot of decks throw in some mid-single-digits
number of generic removal spells and/or counter
spells, and then call it good, spending the
rest of their deck on their engines and synergies
and whatnot, building up their deck’s ability
to function against no opponents.
Then, when a pod of these decks show up to
a table, before too long a player will naturally
start to get ahead, and their opponents won’t
have a lot of recourse for it.
This amplifies power differences, because
if a deck is even a little bit better at what
it does, say, generating an extra half of
a card per turn cycle in value, there will
be nothing to prevent that advantage from
piling up at an interaction-less table.
A compounding factor for this sort of dynamic
is when decks have high variance.
I think the best way to quantify this is to
think about the difference between the deck’s
75th percentile situation, when it’s playing
somewhat better than average, and the deck’s
25th percentile situation, when it’s playing
somewhat worse than average.
Most well-constructed decks will have some
difference between these two, but not a massive
one—your 25th percentile situation won’t
feel great, but you’ll still have plays
you’re setting up for and goals you’re
making progress toward, and maybe you’re
just playing a bit slower, a bit riskier,
or a bit less interactive than usual.
By contrast, a lot of casual EDH decks I’ve
seen were built putting so much emphasis on
the ideal scenario, the big pop off factor,
that as much as 25% or 30% or even 40% of
the time they fail to perform meaningful game
actions.
This comes down to one thing above all others—putting
in too many payoff cards and not enough building
blocks to get there.
I’d categorize payoff cards into two types.
One is amplification cards—cards that convert
your tokens into more tokens, your counters
into more counters, your damage into more
damage, your card draw into more card draw,
and so on.
Some number of these cards can be decent for
a deck, especially cards that can rapidly
lead to a win or which synergize with a type
of card you’ll have especially ample access
to.
However, if you run too many of these and
too few things to be amplified, your game
plan will be fragile.
A while back I had a series of games with
a Zaxara player who would play multiple counter-doublers
and mana-doublers and various other doublers
followed by a single premium hydra, and maybe
a second one if they got lucky.
If that hydra had survived a turn cycle they
probably would have smacked down the table
in short order, but in all the games this
happened, a single removal spell was played,
the Zaxara player had no countermagic, and
just like that they and their pile of synergy
permanents were rendered a total non-threat.
I don’t wanna be too hard on this player
since it seemed like their deck was pretty
newly-built at the time and hadn’t been
tested much, but this is an example of a trap
that’s pretty easy to fall into if you’re
not careful and are just adding stuff that
looks good without thinking about the implications
of those additions.
The other main type of payoff card is what
I’ll call conversion cards—ones that give
you one type of resource as a result of having
or spending a different one.
For example, spending mana to draw cards when
you’ve gained life, drawing cards based
on having a bunch of creatures of the same
type, creating wolves based on how many cards
are in your graveyard, and creating angels
when you play enchantments.
As with amplification cards, these aren’t
inherently bad and are indeed a perfectly
solid type of card in moderation.
But running too many of these resource conversion
cards will have problematic results for deck
consistency—if your deck’s core building
blocks already require you to be doing well
in some capacity, you’re limiting your ability
to get your gameplan going in the first place.
Pair this with running an excessive quantity
of amplification cards as well, and you’ll
find that your deck will struggle to get into
gear consistently, will struggle to play through
interaction, and will struggle to get up off
the floor after it’s been shut down.
Sure, you’ll have the crazy pop off games
from time to time where things line up just
right, but the overall result of a high variance
deck like this is this sort of all or nothing
dynamic that I find very negative, and if
the whole table is playing this sort of deck,
differences in deck power levels will naturally
be amplified wildly.
When one player gets the lucky pop-off whereas
the others get stuck with dead hands full
of unmet payoff cards, and especially when
nobody has interaction to close this sort
of gap in performance, decks can feel poorly
matched and power imbalanced even when they’re
the exact same power level.
As a foil to these sorts of decks, I’m going
to dig back into my past for a moment and
talk about a couple decks I built a few years
ago.
From 2019 to 2022, my playgroup, mostly made
up of broke college students at that point,
played exclusively with a pool of ten $30
EDH decks, and we agonizingly tuned and pruned
and fully rebuilt these decks when needed
until each of these decks played to a power
we were satisfied with.
The end result of this process was a pool
of decks that are not like most casual EDH
decks—these decks have been brought to life
in a setting that is almost competitive in
nature, where there is a meta to keep up with
and adapt to, where each deck is played dozens
of times over with every single win and loss
tracked, and where decks that don’t make
the cut, that don’t win a lot of games,
are scrapped without further question.
In this environment, decks are built with
a high degree of consistency and a lot of
interaction, because these factors lead decks
to win more games in this sort of faux-competitive
environment.
This fact, paired with the low budget, resulted
in a format where resiliency and ability to
grind were the most important factors for
a deck.
The funny thing is, despite these decks being
built on a low budget and designed to play
exclusively against each other, most of these
decks still hold up in games with decks that
are much more powerful on paper, and a big
piece of this is because of their relationship
with interaction.
Take a Dimir rogues list I built—it runs
six counterspells, six removal spells, two
modal cards that can counter or remove, and
three stax cards.
In addition, the proactive cards in the deck
don’t rely on it being ahead or avoiding
opposing interaction—even something like
Bident of Thassa generates acceptable amounts
of value with a single evasive creature, of
which the deck is running 25.
These factors work together to make a deck
that is very flexible, and which can perform
actions like hindering its opponents, chipping
in damage, and drawing extra cards even when
it’s behind.
Not only this, but the high watermark of the
deck is genuinely pretty high, with 30+ damage
combat steps, massive draw, extra turns, and
forcing opponents to discard their hands all
options on the table for the deck, and these
plays are important for allowing the deck
to get to the finish line once it’s a bit
ahead.
A Rakdos discard deck from the same pool is
similarly heavy on interaction—it’s running
ten cards plus the commander for removal,
as well as 25 cards that cause opponents to
discard cards.
The deck’s cards also work well on their
own as a matter of necessity—when a deck’s
gameplan involves forcing the table into a
hellbent state, it’s not gonna play a bunch
of stuff that requires lots of setup because
that’s the exact sort of deck it’s looking
to disorient and hinder through discard spells.
Both of these decks are consistent, grindy,
and interaction-dense, leading them to fit
in quite well at a variety of different tables,
and always feel like they’re contributing
something to the game even when other decks
have significantly stronger cards.
When I reflect on games with these old decks,
there’s something almost paradoxical at
play.
These highly-optimized decks, decks that are
overwhelmingly dedicated to nuts-and-bolts
functionality over all else, led to gameplay
that was way more fun to me than a lot of
games with more conventional EDH decks that
have wacky card choices and perform lots of
big, splashy plays.
Playing decks that are packed with interaction
and also resilient to setbacks leads to fewer
feel-bad I’m-doing-nothing moments, and
way more moments where it feels like you’re
actually playing a multiplayer game where
different players are trying to navigate their
way to a win while keeping their opponents
in check.
And this is certainly not to say that playing
with a pool of hyper-optimized $30 decks is
only the way to achieve this—there are plenty
of things that people find fun about EDH that
won’t be found in an environment like this,
and there’s a reason my play group doesn’t
play exclusively with these decks anymore.
However, I think it’s worthwhile to consider
these sorts of decks as an example of how
EDH can be played.
We can think about EDH decks along a spectrum,
with the most interactionless, high variance
decks out there on one end of things, and
then decks like these which prioritize consistency,
resiliency, and interactiveness above all
else over on the opposite end.
If you’re finding your games too frequently
feeling like a roll of the dice, where some
person happens into an insane opening and
then runs away with the game, just know that
swinginess is a malleable feature.
You can move along this spectrum of gameplay,
and reducing the swinginess of your games
can be as simple as following the two deckbuilding
tips I’ve been mentioning in this video—running
more interaction, and improving a deck’s
consistency and resiliency by removing payoff
cards that are unnecessary or difficult-to-fulfill.
Doing these things will generally reduce the
frustrating feeling of playing a deck that
feels like it’s doing nothing, and a table
with relatively consistent, interactive decks
will feel much more dynamic and balanced regardless
of how powerful each of those decks actually
are.